indeed i'm going to talk about imitation
learning and reinforcement learning i
just want to give you kind of an
overview on the field so it's
educational and how we we can combine
them to actually um yeah solve uh some
previously
intractable tasks
so
indeed as a as you said i'm
a senior scientist at phillips research
i'm also a tv i have kind of a diverse
background i work on 3d scanning
technology biomedical data analysis and
so on
and at philips i'm working on
ai applied to
um so
indeed i presented last year you can
find here the uh the the pi data talk
um yeah and if you're interested come
talk to us so it's uh it's pretty pretty
cool stuff we are doing there at tv i'm
focusing more on an efficient and
explainable ai so here's something that
i did at google on how to understand
what's going on inside the deep neural
network and i will also get back to that
later i also have others so please feel
free to reach out later
but now something completely different
[Music]
so i'm going to talk about imitation
learning reinforcement learning and then
i will use the bottle competition to
kind of
explain them in a
how you can combine them and
specifically with the bot that i
developed which is called mimi bot
and
i promise you i don't have equations on
the slides so it's usually it's a it's a
good sign
so what is imitation learning what is
reinforcement learning so i really like
this picture is from a recent paper um
let's let's assume you have an
environment it can be a video game
simulation
simulation of a machine like a phillips
scanner a
small machine or actually a user working
on a
on a on a web page you have this
environment now you want to have an
agent to be able to operate in this
environment and take actions and modify
the environment
so how do we train these actions so the
we can take the imitation learning
around and we have an expert like a
human also interacting with the
environment and the human receives some
observations so look at the environment
and take some actions
now what we can do we can have a model
in between that is just
perceiving the same as the human is
doing and taking the same actions so in
a way it's like a classification task
where you want to
learn just try to predict the actions
that the the human is doing
okay so that's that's kind of uh one
approach the other one is the what you
do with reinforcement learning uh you
still have your observations we we call
them state
and we need to take some actions as well
to interact with the environment but now
we don't have an expert that is telling
us
how to actually do these actions right
so at the beginning the agent usually
takes just random actions so it can just
do something and probably will fail
because there is no notion of the task
that has to perform think about driving
a car or playing a video game
so the difference here is that the
environment gives a reward signal
which can be how far you are from the
from your end goal during uh driving
driving a car right so or how close you
are to the middle of the road or your
score in a video game
and this reward is then used to train
your agent so if you get high reward you
are basically trying to give incentives
to the agent to continue doing this good
action given the current state
and this is rather complicated stuff um
but now in few recent years
yeah
improved a lot as a methodology i'll get
back to that later so this is kind of
the the setting
and let's get started with imitation
learning um
it's a
you have a lot of different applications
so different implementations i will just
talk about one which is behavioral
cloning which is extremely simple
is the basically the most simple
approach that you can have and if you
have an environment you can code it
like in just a few hours right so it's
super simple what you just do you just
take the observations that the user the
the the expert is having and you just
take the action that the expert is doing
on the environment and you just treat it
as a classification problem
and again so you just collect them and
yeah you just train if you have a
your classifier
that can be implemented in
with the traditional methods or deep
learning it's it's rather
straightforward approach that you can
take and actually this is a rather
old methodology actually the first paper
on this is from 1995
presented at eurips and actually funny
thing it was already a
neural network based approach and here
basically they had
it was based on a self-driving car so
the the one of the first uh
uh approaches there so we you had a
human driving a camera on the car
the camera was then very small a video
30 by 32 which then was used to uh put
into a neural network and the network
had to predict the action that the user
was taking how much it was steering the
wheel
okay so that's
very again very simple approach
but also doesn't work
all the time and here's the explanation
yeah so you may have that
your agent
is not really seeing all possibilities
that you have in the real world and so
this is a funny gift that i found
very
uh closely matching uh what i wanted to
say so let's say that you have your uh
your car your uh your driving car in
your environment and you ask the expert
to drive it around so what they usually
do they do something reasonable right so
they just stay in the middle of the road
and they maybe just go a bit outside but
let's say now you have your agent that
you're just trying on this distribution
of trajectories that you have and at
some point for some reason it's not
perfect it's just drifting a bit
so as you can see the there the the red
line as soon as it drifts a bit yeah it
has no data because the expert never
tried to go
so far out of the road right and then
you basically have a catastrophic
failure because
the agent never saw an example like that
so that's the main issue with the with
the behavioral cloning
in the overall
imitation learning there are other
approaches that
try to address this but they tend to go
in the direction of reinforcement
learning
okay so i found this tutorial
at
icml2018 very insightful so if you want
to
dive a bit deeper i recommend to to have
a look the videos are on the on youtube
and also the slides are online so if you
want to dive a bit more in the topic uh
yeah you can go there
okay so that's about imitation learning
let's have a look now at reinforcement
learning
reinforcement learning became rather
famous
recently yeah because of several things
that happen it's basically the engine
behind alphago the google the the
um the
algorithm from uh deepmind which is uh
like the
ai research lab from google that one uh
against the
listedo in go like ango is this board
game that was previously thought
untractable because it's it's a very
large uh
board game compared to chess where you
have way more actions that you can take
and yeah so that's that's basically um
well alphago was the first one and then
we had
alpha zero which is again an extension
of alphago that can be deployed
and it's actually relying more heavily
on reinforcement learning than than
alphago
and what i wanted to show there is that
this alpha zero is just one single
algorithm it's like a blueprint
for an algorithm that can act in a in an
environment and the environment here is
is the board game it can be chess uh it
can be shogi can be go right so the
environment is the board game you can
think about a position
like a move an action that you can take
in this environment and the same
algorithm can be then trained uh to
actually
act on these different environments and
here you can see okay the green bars are
basically telling you that
alpha zero can actually beat the best uh
um stock fishes like a chess a chess
engine uh but also other in other video
game other board games like uh shogi and
go and it's a it's uh it's the let's say
the state of the art
all right so
but you can go beyond that uh this is
we're just looking at the the board
games uh you can also have it in the
real world and you can
inter do an interplay with for example
with robotics and this is a work from uh
from open ai and where they actually
took this manipulator that was not
really um
in a way funny thing it was not very
successful this manipulator the it's a
commercial product that was not selling
because it was too difficult to control
and that's actually they showed that you
can actually control it now with the
reinforcement learning approach if you
simulate so you simulate your
manipulator in a in a in a virtual
environment you do
the task in this case was rotating the
cube and showing uh different uh letters
and also doing for example pivoting like
rotating the cube sliding in the end
or
just using the the the finger to rotate
in this direction so yeah you can go
here there are a lot of cool videos and
and
it was a nice
approach because it showed that you can
do the simulation in a virtual
environment and then go to the real
world do some adaptation and still have
some good performance
and the reason why i want to show these
is actually that
why go in the virtual environment in the
first place right why don't we do just
reinforcement learning
with the real with the real object
and the reason for that is that
one key drawbacks of reinforcement
learning is that it's very sample
inefficient
it means that in order to understand
what to do you need to do a lot of
trials and errors so you just do some
action you fail and the reward is
negative so you stop doing that action
you get a new one that is good and then
you get a positive feedback but then
again you reach a new point where you
don't know what to do you fail negative
reward and you continue like that and
it's very
lengthy process
so and indeed so we try to go more and
more on simulations and so that we are
more efficient
if you want to dive a bit deeper
i suggest i recommend this book as a
reinforcement learning and introduction
by saturn bartow is very good one and
he's also just is really looking at the
old field from the very early if you are
if you know about dynamic programming
you can actually see it as a case of
reinforcement learning
and
or use it for solving a reinforcement
loading problem you can have these monte
carlo methods that are heavily based on
randomness
and
nowadays the most used one is called
temporal difference learning
for which deep reinforcement learning is
part of
and i'll go
a bit deeper on deep reinforcement
learning
but again so this is the book and the
cool thing about the field is that
nowadays you know all the fancy
algorithms are implemented in using
python
and we have very good baseline so this
stable baseline
repo
it's it's fantastic basically all the
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
agents are there and the very cool thing
is that open ai
release a python environment like an
abstraction of the pi of of an
environment right so what is an
environment you need an observation you
need actions they did that abstraction
and they called it open aig
and which means that if you want to have
your algorithm a new reinforcement
learning on your problem you just need
to implement the environment using that
api and then you can use one of the
stable baseline to solve your problem so
it's very easy to get started
and yeah so that's that's rather
exciting i will get back to to it later
because this is actually not going to
work on the on the problem that i'm
going to show later so all these fancy
algorithms will not work
okay so what is deep reinforcement
learning that i'm going to focus on a
bit more that came out in 2015 with
again a paper from a deep mind so it was
kind of a revolutionary paper where they
said okay we always did reinforcement
learning uh with kind of traditional
methods now we just add deep learning to
it
and how do we do that
and for which problem so the problem was
okay let's develop a reinforcement
learning solution that can play all kind
of atari games
this is arkanoid
is one of the games that
they they demonstrated their solution
against
and um yeah basically the they they
learned to uh to play any kind of video
game so the input to the agent the
observation was just the rgb uh
image that was coming out from from the
video game and the actions are were just
the uh the um
the position of the joystick or the
press of a of of the button
and so this is actually an example of
what the agent learned to do this is
just one uh one game and you can see
that he's actually playing actually
learned to do a very nice trick that he
learned to put the ball on top of the
line of blocks so that is very efficient
in uh
in playing the game so that's that and
that's actually a funny thing also if
this one if you there is some some very
nice videos on youtube where you can
actually see that the agent learns
this behavior after millions of uh play
as i said it's very sampling efficient
means that you really need to do a lot
of examples
but that's a very cool one
so how how is this implemented so as i
said you get as input your your rgb
image
and then what you have you just have a
bunch of convolutions that you learn
right so if you are familiar with deep
learning it's just a combination of a
series of convolutional operators that
you learn over time
and
then you go just to
neurons that are activated so basically
you just
well let's say you can just think about
these as a as vectors
and you just learn operations to go from
one vector from the other to the other
but at the same time you can you can
just see this as a black box that
matches the input to one of those
operations like the joystick operation
so go up left right
up and push a button
and and then what we what we do we just
train with this uh
trial and error and we and we try to
optimize our agent
and then you also have a very cool thing
that you can do you can also try to
understand how the agent is thinking and
that was actually in this original paper
uh i find it very cool each point here
is a one state one observation one state
in the game
and you can see that and they are close
together if the agent
thinks they are similar in terms of a
contest
context in the game
and they are called according to the
value the notion of value how how
valuable is this position how much close
i am to winning and you can actually see
that there are some groups and they
correspond to similar position on the
board this is a space invaders
and
you kind of have a map of how the agent
is thinking and and you can also see
that has this kind of a
group of states that are not
considered valuable so you're probably
going to be losing soon and others that
are pretty valuable
and so you just train these and and
that's uh that's that's pretty cool
now
okay this is all good i mentioned we
have you can just implement your own
environment you can um
uh reuse the stable baselines let's see
a case where this actually doesn't work
because we are there are some reasons
and i'll get back to that later and i'll
use the bottle uh competition as an
example this is a uh if you want to dive
a bit deeper in it and there are it's
all in python it's all available online
you can imply you can play with it so
what do you do what do we play on so
it's a uh bot ball is based on blog on
the bo blood book board game uh which
was published in 1986
it's a rather complex
board game with a lot actually of video
game implementations so we are close to
the third one is very complex the old
point is like simulating on the board
american football game
in a fantasy setting
which means that you also have
different races that are playing like
elves forks
humans and so on
and
you yeah it's
the rule set is rather complex
and it was a competition of the the ieee
cog which is the biggest conference on
on artificial intelligence for gaming
and at the third edition there were
basically no
machine learning bot that can actually
compete in that so
basically just a scripted agent was much
better and what's the reason okay so the
game is basically like these are you
have your pieces on the board you have
11 you play for 16 16 turns and you just
have to score a touchdown and the other
player is playing against you
there is some randomness in the game
which is you can for example try to
block
an opposing player but then you have to
try to roll a dice and you only have 50
chance to actually uh
yeah um
let's say put the other player a piece
out of the game you also have the
ability to dodge but also there you have
you have to roll a die in this case you
have a 50
chance that he's not gonna throw also
you have to throw the ball and
you can and also there it's there is a
lot of randomness
the problem is that
every time you fail an action
you basically lose a turn so this means
that this is very risky game you have to
do a risk management and also you are
very punished very harshly if you fail
in action
and on top of that if we see the number
of actions that you can do from one turn
to the other in chess you have roughly
30 in go you have 300 for this game you
have 10 to the power of 50. so the the
space of possibility is so huge
and the what i said before you train our
enforcement learning agent by trial and
error but every time that you fail you
are completely out of the game for 116
of your game yeah it's it's it's
difficult to learn
and so how
yeah so this is kind of an idea of the
input space a lot of different actions
where that's basically what the agent
can see
and you we have 20 000 possible input
scalars and we actually take eight
possible 8 000 actions so it's again the
the message is all of this is really
huge
um yeah just
as i said no machine learning uh bot was
able to compete in this uh in the past
so some approaches use
curriculum learning the idea is that you
try to make your board game smaller and
try the agent to be able to learn in
this smaller setting
uh
but indeed these were not able to beat a
scripted bot somewhere you had some kind
of uh uh human defining how the uh the
bot should play
all right so how how did i
kind of
solve this uh in a way uh and actually
we one with this mimik bought the latest
uh uh ball competition against scripted
agents so this is really the the first
and only machine learning based bot that
actually can play in this in this game
um yeah
just a couple of things i don't have too
much time i will just show the
architecture i will not dive into that
but i just want to play a bit how we can
combine behavioral cloning together with
reinforcement learning to improve sample
efficiency
and
and yeah indeed solve this problem
okay so for the model architecture
i think i will not go too much into
detail here this is a
like the deep learning solution that i
have
the cool thing here is that it uses
something called a channel attention to
actually be able to preserve a spatial
information
that is actually quite relevant in the
game again i will not go into it i just
want to mention that
usually when you think about deep
learning you think okay it's something
that i need to
run on a big gpu
and and takes a lot of time actually
this one is rather very optimized it
takes only 20 milliseconds to run on a
laptop cpu and so that's uh that was a
part of the equation but i don't want to
focus on the model itself i want to
to say how we can actually train it
and if we go back to this picture what
you can do we don't have a human expert
because there are yeah i could not play
this for an infinite amount of time for
the
imitation learning what i can do i can
take
a scripted bot that was actually doing
rather relatively good before and just
collect how they can play and i can just
do imitation learning for a scripted bot
and now if i just let two uh two
scripted bots play against each other
for let's say 200 games i can collect
the states and the actions and just then
train a classification model
to
predict the actions and if i do that i
can actually see that the bot that is
trained uh here the behavior or cloning
one can actually beat the random one all
the time all the time and it can
actually beat the scripted one
let's say at least uh win uh here uh
against the scripted one
let's say after of the time and before
basically every machine learning model
was always losing
and of course here is training there is
a bit of overfitting again i will not go
into detail here but
we train our model using behavioral
cloning but of course we cannot expect
to to beat
uh all the time the agent that is
trained against because we are just
trying to imitate so what we can do
instead is say okay we just train with
behavior cloning we have the model is
doing okayh and now we start doing
reinforcement learning we just do some
pre-training with behavioral cloning and
then we do reinforcement learning
unfortunately that doesn't work because
you have something that is called a
policy collapse so your model
the behavioral cloning is not able to
adapt to the new
training environment so here you see the
reward
and the winning rate at the beginning it
was higher so it was playing against the
uh
the scripted bot and winning 40 percent
of the time and after a bit of training
is always losing it's called policy
collapse and we need to find a way to
actually counteract that and the trick
here is that
we can actually combine the two we can
do a reinforcement learning for a number
of iterations we update our model then
we go back and we still use the
information from behavioral cloning and
if we do that we can stabilize uh our
training in such a way that we can um
yeah start learning to act in a
reinforcement learning way in this
environment but of course we are still
grounded to the original scripted bot uh
behavior so
but after a while we can just do
here should be a reinforcement learning
update we can just do a reinforcement
learning update and now our win rate
goes up so we overcome the initial drift
and i'll be soon finished soon
by doing this trick
here actually you see
yeah i'll not go into this i don't have
time i'd say
but as i said before there is a way to
inspect actually what's happening in the
network
so that you can really you can really
dive into that and also
as i said i also skipped that so we have
we have some uh very um hybrid behavior
right so you can also use some scripted
action together with your model
and yeah so it was actually it actually
won the competition uh as i said all
basic um uh stable baseline do not work
that's also why you could see that not
so many people competed because it's you
like existing works uh do not work on in
this setting and just to conclude i
would say to me
the cool thing is that if you have a
problem where you can actually simulate
and you have your let's say control
theory algorithm that already works you
can kind of model the imperfections of
your model
using this approach right so you just
add an extra bit of control you use your
traditional algorithm as a way to ground
uh your solution and you just use this
streak to just try to simulate and get a
bit better right so and that's really
flexible because also you don't have the
nip the human in the loop right so
and with that i think it's better if we
leave some time for q a
i knew it
so uh cool talk thanks they
a lot of these reinforcement learning
demos they're pretty cool because
they're all about video games but then
you also kind of wonder well a video
game that's a simulator you kind of have
the perfect simulation it's still a
really cool demo but like then the
question is how's that going to be
turned into a practical application yeah
any comments on that yeah that's why i
showed the the the the one from open ai
with the manipulator because that's that
was an attempt there was also a lot of
controversy about this one because they
kind of cheated in a way they had a lot
of extra sensors then to do the
translation
um
yeah i think the the need for the
simulation environment and how accurate
that is it's super crucial if you don't
have that one um well you are yeah
exactly at the same time you can also
see
yeah i mean translation to the physical
world is difficult that's the thing
but you can actually have simulate a lot
of digital stuff very accurately and
there it's where it can shine a bit more
right so and but indeed i see the
problem right so and i was also at
phillips is a topic of interest but also
there if you have a let's say an imaging
device then you need to simulate that
right so and that's that's the tricky
thing yeah
any other questions
thank you very much for the presentation
so question which is related to the
previous question if for example we have
behavior cloning from different users
from multiple users do you think that
this would help
our reinforcement
learning later because then you can even
group users together and for example
identify
patterns between users and uh i don't
know kind of boost your information
learning algorithm
uh yeah absolutely i mean the it that
depends on your policy let's say the
policy network so if your policy network
is able to model the behavior of
different agents
then yeah just go for it right so the
question is is your policy able to uh to
represent a sub-populations of users
and that's why
deep reinforcement learning is actually
uh rather popular it because it can do
that right so it can
adapt you can you can well it's just a
high-dimensional space where you're
acting